bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono vari j
mi vien da ridere perché questo è il
menù più bello che io abbia mai visto
nella storia dei videogiochi creato da
ahmad al hakim al dah grande re mohammed
crown far bene clicca su play cliccare
su almeno quello a ok bene ci siamo
ragazzi se non sono un gorilla
bellissimo plan seriamente la cosa più
bella che abbia un giorno scotti gara di
ombelichi io sono più bello non mi dico
come la mettiamo
che cazzo calmi un attimo è la madonna
che cazzo successo sono vivo l'aspetto
saprò ministra gorilla camiscioni
studioso di siri henkel avrei avenue si
deve andare in città a uccidere
qualsiasi essere umano che io vedo bene
e io non sapevo che dei gorilla
abitassero in queste case comunque
comunque ragazzi la cosa non è che mi ha
fatto benissimo come se io lanci barile
poi ma vicino
funghi ragazzi la cosa bella intanto
sorgono gli alberi mentre ci avviciniamo
la particolarità di saw gorilla che
lancia le scoregge e questa è una cosa
che gli fa onore o buoni che lancia
anche dei barili capitolato per gli tira
fuori però va bene devo capire il perché
dico a caso mio dio
cos'è successo sono morto da capire e
poi risorgo h comunque il gioco della io
non so come ho fatto a non scoprire
certe cose io mi pento della mia vita il
suo livello di paghe impressionante
buongiorno devo capire lamentato
sfornano persone tu hai una cresta che
gli inguardabile che cazzo scappi
potete porre fine alla mia vita per
cortesia chiedo perché mi fa troppo
strano comunque luncheon barile giusto
per sicurezza magari che esplode in
faccia è diventato un gorilla
ecco cosa scoppi il monito è la moda
vieni qua la pace diventano gorilla no
raga io sto gioco non lo sto capendo
cosa strana
non è possibile ma i ragazzi ho ucciso
quattro esseri umani fino a chi inventa
non li gorilla soli colpisco dagli enti
cazzo a parco è sono sono morto io e
bellissimo io non sono affatto a non
scoprirlo prima ma dovevo assolutamente
scoprirlo
adesso scappa pure gorilla dovevo capire
cosa fare della mia vita prima perché
c'è un barile che scappa che cazzo
succede cosa fai tu vieni qua magari
viziando e gas
lo prendo inter ok l'ha preso la preso
prima lo imita ci sono i barili che
continuano a girare a caso non ho capito
perchè comunque ok amico mio sei caduto
nel modo migliore in cui potessi cadermi
credimi se il mio idolo perché è scappi
vieni qua io ti amo se io nel caso ti
facessi è tornato adesso è tornato umano
perfetto se io io comunque dopo questo
ho visto tutto ero un che ragazzi
credevo che god simulator avesse toccato
il fondo
stai giocando a un due tre stella zio
che vi posso io corro più veloce con le
scoregge sta cosa bellissima
bene
guardate come può bellissimi possa
scalare le montagne quigo rita c'è ma io
questa cosa non la sapevo ma il gorilla
sanno scalare le montagne e meglio di
bear grylls c'è una fine a questo gioco
continuano montagne per km e km noi idea
di dove stia andando ma dovunque vada so
che sarò felice
[Applauso]
tonino murru che a parte tutto sto
casino il livello di ed è tanto non mi
faccio domande tanto esplode gente a
caso il livello di bbned io non sto
facendo
non sto giocando sta esplodendo persone
a caso io non sto toccando niente non è
possibile subito io ragazzi ho perso il
mio gorilla come ho fatto a perdermi
ragazzi sono un gorilla invisibile belle
e sexy mancava ai predetti gol simulator
il confronto è un bel gioco praticamente
io mi sono incastrato l'ufficio dove
prova bene mi possa essere un quello sia
attaccato al balcone ragazzi se non
riuscite a recuperare il mio gorilla non
chiedetemi come per che cosa sta
succedendo lì perché ci sono delle
persone in casa c'è un barile che sta
per esplodere non esplode ecco adesso
pau newman posso sparare gli umani così
ma sei serio a creare esseri umani dal
nulla
praticamente fa un miliardo di esseri
umani ragazzi poi faccio una roba
bruttissima stupro di tastiera erano
terminati un ragazzo io soli prova a
fare una roba
mamma mia che botta che riesce formica
se esplode il disastro perché è riuscita
a cadermi in testa al mio barile ci
abbiate pazienza
ecco questo velo questo volevo fare va a
franco morite a tutti madonna in this a
madonna hiroshima volevo cosa state
facendo il trenino gorino io posso
suonare anche igor i se ma rendetevi
conto pioggia di gorilla di esseri umani
tutti insieme macello assol madonna che
disastro è crashato il mondo credo cos'è
successo quello così eh va beh questo è
il mio apro museo ragazzo orgoglioso di
aver giocato o gioca non siete
orgogliosi anche voi di averlo visto a
parte gli scherzi tutto il resto credo
di non aver mai giocato un gioco così
brutto in generale per calciare
ragazzi un disastro gioco non ha un
senso di esistere
i ragazzi a parte tutto a parte i
gorilla sul tetto a parte i gorilla
morti e quelli che hanno ficcato
attestano nell'erba che posso concludere
un episodio su gorilla simulator che è
stato gioco del secolo senza ombra di
dubbio look e ragazzi con quello che
prima che la situazione degeneri e già
non sta messa troppo bene e quindi
ragazze il video è piaciuto cosa se
traccia documento mi piace anche a
facili facebook e come la di vino a
trattanere iscrizione sono resi di
sfilate riuscivi a professionisti belle
ragazze
[Musica]